now how our increasingly Wireless world
is affecting our social behavior
especially among the generation that's
grown up with smartphone look there's
your
books you want to you you want to read a
book with Dad Dash
I you want an iPad
Mom oh not right
now Mama I'll bring the iPad back later
[Music]
okay at our finger tips we have access
to a sea of information entertainment
and virtual connections that were
unfathomable just a couple of decades
ago but at what cost there's an irony in
the heart of our interconnected world
how has our Relentless pursuit of
digital content reshaped the fabric of
our daily lives our relationships and
even the wiring of our brains and can we
do anything about it
[Music]
welcome back to Leed live everybody
today we are going to discuss what
happens in your brain when you watch and
pay attention to all this media and we
have an expert in the house Scott ritma
thank you for joining us today thanks
for having me Scotty I'm excited to have
this guy here because uh for years I
feel like we've kind of traveled around
and and visited very similar spots and
people would always approach us and be
like have you guys heard of Scott ritma
so I'm excited to have you as an expert
how did you get into this stuff by the
way well first of all it's it's it's the
opposite direction I feel like I've I've
arrived at a destination here at Little
Light Studios it's an honor to be with
you guys and it actually people were
handing me your DVDs back you know 2010
11 and Magic Kingdom and I'm I'm
teaching in a classroom teaching Bible
at this time I used to teach history
government economics but I'm teaching
Bible and helping my young people you
know by the spirit of God grow in Christ
and the media is interrupting that and
they're getting immersed in really dark
stuff and addiction and so somebody
gives me your DVDs I'm like man this is
incredible and I got more to say about
this so I just cancelled the Bible
curriculum and for two weeks I I talk to
my students about their media use what
is science telling us how do we
understand the agendas learning about
history propaganda mind control and the
local pastors are like hey could you
preach that at our church cuz we want
that as a sermon and then big camp
meeting conference says hey can you do a
seminar on that the Lord opens door
after door after that and the the the
the the uh curriculum was called media
on the brain and then the sermon was
called media on the brain and then the
camp meeting seminar was called media on
the brain and somebody comes up to me
you're skilled AV people here incredible
incredible equipment and and Technology
you have and this guy comes up he goes
you ought to do this and put it on DVD
these seminars that you're teaching
ought to be out there and that's where
churches were inviting to do it after
that that camp meeting seminar so that's
kind of how we got into this and been at
400 plus churches over the last 12 years
that God's opened the door to really
bring an Awakening to people about not
just what are the effects but what are
the solutions so we do other seminars on
parenting and true education I love to
talk about current events in Prophecy
but um yeah it's it's good to be here
with you guys this conversation is
exciting to me praise the Lord you know
it's really neat to see how God when he
opens up a door and you are willing to
walk through that door I mean things
happen that you never would have dreamed
in a million years I mean I never I
never thought in a million years I'd be
sitting here discussing Bible topics
every day you know like this is this has
been a joy in in my life and I know like
you have blessed so many people with
your ministry so I'm excited to to hear
about this if you guys haven't um
checked out Scott rum's Ministry we'll
put a link in the description below but
he has a lot of information you're going
to hear a little bit about it today um
but uh let's just let's just kind of
break into this like talk a little bit
about like what's going on because
people people I think have a hard time
separating that it's entertainment and
what does this really have an impact
upon me well it's not it there's there
are agendas right the Bible says see to
it that no one takes you captive through
Hollow and deceptive philosophy don't be
conformed to this world so it just
entertainment is a very surface level
really a deceptive that's that's the
mask that it's harmless that it's not
going to affect us in fact when you get
whist whle blowers out of big Tech out
of the entertainment industry they admit
they have agendas um that agenda might
be uh a sort according to a certain
worldview or even just a corporate
business model of like the CEO of HBO
came out and it's like we're in the
business of building addicts building
video addicts we want to build as many
addicts as we can across as many
franchises as we can right so for
somebody girls is their Obsession and
that's why they subscribe to HBO for
somebody else it's boxing for somebody
else it's Thrones for somebody else it's
it's Silicon Valley and the key for us
is making sure that we're building up
addicts over time across our different
genres because unlike David's business
we're not selling advertising we're
selling subscriptions he just said it
just bluntly like that addiction is a
serious issue it's a mental health
condition in the Diagnostics and
statistics manual the Psychiatry
Community they list media addictions
there now and then you had the um the
one of the presidents the first
president of Facebook Sean Parker
founding it with Mark Zuckerberg he came
out maybe like 5 six years ago and he
said we deliberately were giving him a
little dopamine hit here giv him a
little dopamine hit there to keep them
on the platform keep them doing what we
need them to do to do and he says it was
Mark it was me it was this guy on that
platform he names all these people you
remember this quote and he goes they did
it we did it on purpose and we knew what
we were doing and we did it anyway
speaking at an axios event Wednesday
Parker who worked with Mark Zuckerberg
to develop Facebook with a bombshell
claim saying the site was intentionally
built to hook you that thought process
was all about how do we consume as much
of your time and conscious attention as
possible it's a social validation
feedback loop because you're exploiting
a
vulnerability in in human psychology the
38-year-old Mogul admits he along with
other pioneers of social media knew what
they were doing we understood this
consciously and we did it
anyway it literally changes your
relationship with Society with each
other it's crazy to think that all those
guys too they were basically in the same
class at Stanford you know it was called
like the Facebook class or something you
have all these Silicon Valley startups
and they're listening to the in the I
don't remember what class it was but
they were listening to psychology or
something about Operate conditioning and
all these kind of techniques yeah BF
Skinner and it just kind of clicked with
them like hey we could use this for
media and the next thing you know
they're like all billionaires right yeah
I mean that that that hits on the nail
and the head it's all boiling down to
money if you just follow the money like
they're doing this for money the more
that they can show more eyeballs are on
this thing for this amount of time they
can go to the advertisers and be like
hey look if you just put your
advertisement right here x amount of
people are going to soak this in it's
really interesting you know I I say this
the same thing too you you talked about
how people doesn't they don't think it
has an effect on them right we hear that
all the time this and it's really that
that that cognitive dissonance that we
all can be subject to right and and what
way do we take that and I kind of see
two paths with cognitive dissonance
you're either going
to reinforce what it is that that you
believe and and why you believe it and
why you're going the right direction
which leads to
self-justification or you're going to
look at the data and you're going to
think about it and you're say you know
what there's a change that has to be
made there and you're going to go down
the path of
reformation that's that's really your
two options yeah right y Romans 12:2
presents those two conformed or
transformed you'll be conformed to this
world or transformed by the renewing of
your minds and that's the path of
redemption that's the path of wholeness
and healing and joy and God wants to
free us from addictions free us from you
know when we get into the the discussion
about dopamine what's happening in the
brain there is is actually a flood of
dopamine unnaturally like by use of a
drug like by use of pornography or other
media addictions the brain gets flooded
with it and dopamine receptors just
start shutting down and then you become
dependent on that high level of input or
more frequent or a new novel experience
that then delivers that and if you don't
have that I mean I've got brain scans in
the seminars where you see the pleasure
receptors starting to become numbed and
muted and you that person just doesn't
have as much joy and happiness and it's
like God wants us to have joy we're not
we're not saying don't enjoy life we're
saying these designed entertainments are
not actually designed to deliver
sustainable happiness and joy a high
followed by a crash which leads to a
downward spiral every addiction there is
brings greater depression and it's only
one of many chemicals that are at play
you know you have other hormones and
neurotransmitters that are play you have
endorphins you have enlin you have
serotonin you have oxytocin and you know
all these are at play at the same time
it's not just dopamine acting it's all
of them acting in concert if you look at
a Hollywood script you can follow it
with the bio biochemical reactions that
are happening in your body and in your
brain and it's amazing it's it's
essentially biochemical manipulation
absolutely and all of that is natural so
is that response only does it come from
only synthetic sources or can you find
that in nature like do we have that
natural response in in good context
absolutely nature
family accomplishments Doing Hard tasks
and getting the payoff uh eating healthy
natural foods doing good for others
training and I'm going to run a 5k or a
half marathon and then you pays off you
get the runners I mean God designed it
so that when we follow the path he
designed for us that brings the fruit of
the spirit of Joy Satan is not better at
pleasure than God is that's a lie right
and then you look at people like
Nicholas Cardaras who wrote the book
glow kids and he point points out in
there he has treated hundreds of heroin
addicts and Screen addicts and he says
it is easier to treat a heroin addict
than a true screen addict so when we
talk about addiction this is not
hyperbole we're not just throwing a term
out there this is clinical reality it's
in the Psychiatry Bible they call it the
diagnostic I mentioned that the
statistical manual where they they
diagnose these addictions and you can
tell you take the six question survey
and like if I you know if I you know
don't feel normal without it and if I
hide the extent of the problem and you
can you can figure out okay do I have a
problem with this I mean you just look
at those videos of the little kids that
get their iPad taken away from them and
it's like World War III meltdown but
what's the root like what's the Crux of
the difference between the two because
if you you're drawn to Media right so
you get this the same dopamine hit with
using your phone as in like being in
nature and all of that however you're
like you're addicted so to speak with
the the media you have that tantrum
response but not necessarily nature
what's it's the same natural hormones
but a different response what the Crux
of that quantity and stimulant it's
being a stimulant like cocaine like
caffeine the brain takes that in as a
quick fix it's the easy route versus you
got to work at it and then the payoff
happens and the frontal lobe is engaged
with life God's way you're engaging
frontal lobe activity and then that that
brings activity to the pleasure reward
circuit because you followed the correct
route when you target the pleasure hit
the nucleus accumbent gets hit with
these stimul whether Media or drugs and
no activity in the frontal lobe from a
chemical perspective what what we do and
this is in many areas of life is we
increase or we're subject to increases
in concentration beyond their normal
limits yes so a good way to a good
analogy for example is you know are
there natural sugars in fruits yes are
is there salt in naturally found
occurring you know sodium chloride and
potassium chloride found naturally in
potatoes MH yes but high doses what
about is there fats in avocados yes and
coconut right but once all of those are
concentrated and especially all three
together like the trifecta they call it
which is what McDonald's does right
increase the fat increase the salt
increase the sugar now they're in
disproportionate levels of what you're
supposed to be getting and your brain
just goes nuts it's like oh my I I've
got to have more of this right it's the
same kind of thing that's going on with
media it's in disproportionate levels
than you're normally supposed to
experience the proofs in the pudding
though if you sit and you look at the
people that would binge watch something
right how do you feel after you binge
watch it I mean you nobody's like I feel
amazing you go run a 5k like honestly
just compare the two together you go
outside you go camping you're going to
feel totally different than sitting
there watching TV I mean you don't you
don't even need to like open a science
book just like literally like I I feel
better doing this than that that's so
true and going to the diet thing the
average American consumes for every one
calorie that we are eating from a whole
plant food source we are consuming one
of those versus 25 of the everything
else the refined sugars the refined fats
the refined foods and that is making us
less happy it's the standard American
diet the sad diet s a d I love it it's
not just killing us but you become more
depressed when you eat that way when you
eat servings of fruit and vegetables you
add that to your diet there's a
measurable boost of Happ happiness for
each serving of fruit and vegetables
that you add to your diet and they
measured it up to eight additional so
you crowd out that with something better
and you start feeling better the the the
average um young person that I've
surveyed for every one hour that they
are in God's word or in spiritual food
of any kind 25 hours of entertainment
media so it's 25 to1 ratio the same as
the standard American diet going to have
the same effect on our happiness I
remember my dad when I was little he was
like if you want to watch something um
you have to equal whatever you uh read
the Bible it's like I'll eat a cookie
now and then a salad later so as a kid
we were like we'll go outside Dad wow I
want to go back to the argument and
Keith brought up um about oh this
doesn't affect me comparing it to people
have different reactions when it comes
to addiction different thresholds so to
speak I don't know if that's the right
word like you can smoke once someone can
smoke once and be fine other someone
else they smoke once and they're hooked
for like you know 10 years or what have
you is that the same when it comes to
Media problem is you principles are
built on averages and Norms they're not
built on
extremes right so you don't build the
case on the person's that's like well my
brain just operates I know somebody like
this actually he's very intelligent like
we're talking he probably could have
gone to MIT his brain just works very
differently you can sit him down in
front of entertainment media and he just
can't stop thinking and analyzing the
thing the whole time it's going on to
the point where it would like be
annoying you know if you want to enjoy
something it would be annoying to sit
down with him and go through that
because he's he's just constantly
analyzing the thing and thinking and and
his frontal loobe just isn't shutting
down it's like it's not being bypassed
like a normal
individual but you don't build those
principles off of the extreme case right
yeah are there people that are like that
yes but they're going to be fewer and
farther between yeah also I like to
think of addiction and every mental
health measure depression versus
happiness I like to think of it as like
on a spectrum you know the best
attention span the worst attention span
the the the most peace the most anxiety
if you look at every mental health
measure on a spectrum rather than just
seeing you know the this point on the
Spectrum over it's called a certain
that's happiness yeah yeah exactly it's
you know you have depression you have
you know there's no blood test there's
no brain scan that establishes exactly
what these conditions are but every one
of us wants more peace less anxiety more
happiness less Depression more attention
span less low attention span and less
addiction uh so where am I in the
Spectrum on any one of these is is not
really the most important question the
question is what am I doing to take
myself the right direction on the
Spectrum more nature exposure more
face-to-face relationships physical
activities doing real things I've got a
session in the media mind seminar called
how to be human again it's like we got
to ReDiscover that and so you know if
the more of this we're doing even if
somebody's like well it doesn't affect
me as bad as it does somebody else as
badly it as it does you know Joe down
the street well is this choice that
you're making helping you go the
direction you want to go and it's not a
mandate it's not a judgment it's not
somebody coming in and telling you what
you got to do it's just you got to think
through it for yourself and evaluate
your own life and I always think that
that idea is kind of a logical fallacy
anyway because if it didn't affect you
at all you wouldn't do
it right mhm so why are you watching
that because it's supposed to bring this
temporary happiness and joy like if it's
a comedy or something because you want
to laugh right you can't say it doesn't
affect me what they're trying to say or
at least what I think people are trying
to say is ultimately when I sit down and
watch something it is not going to
fundamentally change what I believe as a
Christian I think that's what people are
really saying you know going to change
my beliefs one way for them to figure
that out is to go 10 days or 30 days
without because you can't say it doesn't
affect me unless you have something to
compare it with right so you do a fast
and you say I'm going to I'm going to
establish a Bible study program I'm
going to commit myself to this
devotional activity there are things I
know God is asking me to do that I've
been hesitating I'm going to do those
instead of entertainment I'm going to do
a fast from social media and then at the
end of 30 days or 40 days or even just
10 days it's like a new set of lenses
when you go to the the optometrist you
know you may think you're seeing fine
yeah I don't need glasses NE neily but
then when you get to the third line down
he's like read that one wait I'm
supposed to be able to read that and I
guess I am seeing a little blurry and
you find that out by a test this has
happened to me recently have you yeah
really I can't stand glasses have you uh
heard about that that um
the the poll they did with college
students and they're like just just a
simple poll and they're like okay you're
not going to have your phone for 24
hours and they measure their anxiety
levels they haven't even removed the
phone anxiety levels go up just the
thought of not having their phone for 24
hours let alone actually removing it
from their lives made their anxiety
levels go up so is the phone the
solution to anxiety Then or is that just
a sign of an addiction it's a sign of
addiction that's what I always tell
people it's like if you want to know
you're addicted put it away for a week
yeah well yeah I think people are are
genuinely thinking that you know like
I'm set in my ways and and there's not
much that you're going to dislodge me
and and this was um very interesting
when we interviewed a hypnotherapist for
one of our our earlier projects and he
said there's like there's these things
in your life that are very hard to
dislodge your belief in God your family
Dynamics there there's there's a number
of things that that pretty much nobody
in this room is going to tell you
something that's going to change that
but the hypnotherapist said it is
possible to change your ideas and it's
not changing like what you think about
them it's how you feel about them and if
they can attach a negative feeling to
that person or that thing so like let's
say your mom you've got these beliefs
that you that only you understand about
your mom I'm not going to tell you
anything different about your mom but if
I go you know your mom left you at
school one time and you know how'd that
make you feel like she she forgot about
you if you attach enough of those
negative feelings pretty soon you can
change somebody's feelings about their
mom and so I think that's what's
happening here there's things that
people go oh I don't think that I would
ever change my belief system in God but
we've looked at so many pieces of media
that have negative negative off opposite
things of God and and it's like over
time how can that not change you yeah
I'd like to push back on what you said a
little bit Keith I'm curious about your
answer what would you say do you think
it's fair to say that the anxiety that
those students were getting was not
necessarily directly because of the
phone but what the phone represents
connectivity information X Y and Z so
removing that removed all those things
that they've attached but that's
assuming that they don't have those
things if they don't have the phone
right so it's gotten to the point so if
you remove my phone can I not connect
with people anymore depends context as
suppose right and and the most I would
say most college students most Americans
that are living in a modern age you
remove this what do I still have still
have an iPad I still have a computer I
can still communicate with people it
means I'm not getting necessarily phone
all together remove electron if you went
on a media fast that that sounds like
heaven go back me but think you remove
all media let's say you're on a college
campus away from home so you you think
that you're losing connectivity to
whoever who's off campus or if that's
how you do your studies online and all
this all these things granted someone
could say go to the library but do you
do you understand the question I'm
thinking of someone who might come up
with that like oh it's not that I'm
addicted to my phone like the
thing yeah my life is wrapped around
this thing this my calendars and all of
that you know I want to ask is it real
connectivity yeah or is the brain
perceiving that as a social bond that
was made through that text through that
post through that social media
interaction and in reality God designed
for us to be in person face to face and
hugging and loving the people that are
closest to us and throughout history the
Human Social sphere has been pretty
small you know 100 150 people that I
know pretty well and then within that
Circle you know the people that I'm
tightest with and now we have the
hundreds and and thousands and we call
that social when really you know that
these forms of media are good to get
truth out to to communicate in an
efficient manner so it's not a
condemnation of it all but we shouldn't
call it social I I've I've begun
referring to it as antisocial media
because it is antisocial and when
college students are taken off social
media for one week just seven days no
social media their loneliness scores
drop 36% why is that what happens in
place of you I think you know the answer
why why do you think um well replacing
that the void so now that this is not in
my life I'll probably go out more
interact with people yeah okay yep um
Scotty you brought up a comment that
probably a lot of parents watching might
resonate with of you take the device
away from the child uh child whether
it's um a toddler or a teenager and boom
there's a tantrum mhm like can you
address what a parent might feel or any
solutions to that maybe the cause we've
talked about the cause but if there's
any other uh causes or connectiveness a
teacher you take away the stuff from a
from a student what happens yeah yeah
and and they'll recover they'll recover
it it is you just say that again like
it's not the end of the world yeah just
you you haven't destroyed the child yes
just make a decision now to do life
differently and their brain will develop
and come alive in fact there's a study
Los Angeles they took kids out of the
city out of the classroom out of the
media inundation that we live in and
just took them into the mountains took
them on a camping outing and as a group
and they were to socialize and do team
building exercises no media half the
students fifth graders half of them are
in that experience the other half are
back home as the control group in their
desk playing their video games at home
after school Etc and they looked at
emotional intelligence because that's
one of the big concerns about the
children it's it's it's temper tantrums
are emotional self-regulation issues but
there's also emotional intelligence
challenges facial expressions eye
contact human communication verbal and
non-verbal nonscreen real human living
and socializing they found after just
five days their EQ scores jumped in just
five days um there's Dr Victoria Dunley
who's done reset your child's brain and
parents come to her with their
adolescence or their children with all
these diagnosed and named addictions and
disorders and and depression and all of
it and and they don't come to her for a
pharmaceutical solution she's the lady
that does the media fast 3 weeks no
media 80% of her patients have the
majority of their symptoms gone in 3
weeks see this is the beauty of God he
creates a system with neuroplasticity
that you can you can actually you get
yourself in trouble and God goes you
know what if you just take a break back
off and try my ways you can change them
yeah and then then there's also the Char
development issues that come with the
okay well you threw a 10 for tantrum so
I'm just going to give in and what kind
of behavior are you reinforcing as a
parent you know that's that's guess what
the next time you've already showed them
guess what all I got to do is throw a
temper tantrum to get what I want so how
long does that continue throughout the
their life if they they do that in the
entirety of their their home experience
they just start to do it with their
friends they start to do it when they
get older I saw a video of a little kid
was telling his dad you take my iPad I'm
going to hurt you it's like this little
kid you know and it's like what all I
mean so my next question is and then
what so the parent takes away the device
or the whole family goes on a trip 5
days they see the positive effects yes
then you go back home you know or what
if the kid H the child has their classes
online or whatever so they they need to
have they need to have access to that
media where do you how do you balance it
out so that the Tantrum isn't reinforced
or anything like that it's a LIF
it's not a it's not a one-time solution
there's a book called The Tech wise
family by uh Andy Crouch and he has
what's in there called the 10 Tech wise
commitments or I think he calls them
commitments or Commandments one of the
two he's kind of playing off the Ten
Commandments anyway he was the executive
editor for Christianity Today and their
family's lifestyle was not built around
media right so you're probably familiar
with the quote Anton L called the
television and the satanic family altar
so in their home they made the decision
when they kind of saw the early early
stages of like oh boy this stuff is
coming so he's like okay the center of
our home is filled with things like
paper and pencil crayons musical
instruments all this kind of stuff so
that it's filled with things that help
the child be creative and expressive but
the other things were not in the center
of their home they were on the periphery
as he said he calls them the glowing
rectangles so they made the decision
that they would not have a television in
their house until their children
youngest child was in double digits and
he tells a story of his daughter her
friend comes over and the television
when they got it it went in the basement
so it was kind of like out of sight
right out of sight out of mind so much
so that his daughter when she had a
friend come over the daughter asked her
hey do you want to go downstairs and
watch something on TV and his daughter
looks up at her friend and she's like
like we have a
TV which as apparent that you know what
he was trying to accomplish is a very
proud moment for him because it it
wasn't in the Forefront of her mind and
that's why I say it has to be more of a
lifestyle like your lives don't revolve
around that thing yeah absolutely and in
instead of TV being the center of the
home the full-time parent especially
with those little children the presence
of that parent the loving attachment
that takes place is is essential is
critical for all Child Development
measures and in our house it's funny you
mentioned the TV we we got a TV and we
don't have TV we don't have the you know
the services but we also have a felt
board remember the Felts like theh and
you put up the little Joseph with his
multicolored coat and so we've got the
little one who does the Felts and behind
the feltboard is the TV screen so people
walk into our home would not even know
we have it but hey we want to watch a a
really good sermon you know or we want
to watch a nature video together
and it's interesting when you actually
consult the sort of tech gurus in
Silicon Valley the young adults with the
kids in the home how do they do life
differently it's more like what you're
describing they put their kids in the
Waldorf School where they're doing
gardening and pencil and paper and
they're not they're not high-tech
families like the rest of us are and
famously Steve Jobs said my kids have
never used an iPad Bill Gates kids only
45 minutes isn't that amazing bizarre
it's like the people making it are the
people who are most protect
because they recognize more than anyone
else like how powerful it is they're
they're leaning into that going this is
this this thing's going to take off like
storm it's also hypocritical absolutely
intentional about destroying other
people's lives but you want to keep
yours as a perfect Sanctuary I I I want
to ask you um what is the percentage
that parents actually get with their
kids I I I I can't remember the numbers
but I think it was like something
ridiculous like they spend 15 minutes a
day with a kid it's not enough in fact
teens are spending twice as much time on
their smartphone than any conversation
with their parent all time with their
parents combined but it goes both ways
sometimes I get the call like we got to
have brother ritsa come and do the media
on the brain seminar because our young
people and then you look at the data
okay yeah in 2016 we reached the point
and it's even higher now during covid
especially but um it was nine hours per
day for teens for entertainment and
social media nine hours per day and
that's a problem parents are nearly
eight hours per day of entertainment and
social media parents are spending twice
as much time just watching Netflix than
all quality time with their children
combined you as a parent have a lot of I
mean your kids are going to do what you
do right and then some so if you want
them to not do that if you want them to
read a book you need to read a book if
you want them to go play outside you
should go play outside with them yeah
yeah especially since some sometimes for
some people they think that is quality
time sitting down and watching a movie
with my kid like that's quality time so
they're both you know leving leveling up
on on this media um Keith a thought that
came to M as you were speaking is a
parent might think oh but you know I
need to have these elements in my home
or else you know my kid will have
problems making friends or or they might
start getting bullied or they might get
out of touch because X Y and Z and um
you know my home was similar to as you
describe we didn't have a TV in the main
living
space there are so many lessons that can
be learned about healthy boundaries
about how to find healthy friendships um
when you're put in that context where
you have to speak up that you're
different you know and so if if the the
goal should be as you're training up
your child so they can make it through
life not just in this context of
childhood and so if you invite children
over to your home not only is that that
a witnessing opportunity or just an
opportunity to learn a different
lifestyle but it's also how does your
child or how can you teach your child
how to handle that confrontation of oh
how about we watch a movie oh you know
there's no TV how about we color or what
have you and see first off children are
are pretty forgiving number one they're
pretty adaptable number two and and once
given the opportunity to understand why
something is happening why something is
different they're pretty open to go
along with it and so I think we've
become very limiting in our teaching of
little people you know little children
not understanding that they're going to
grow up to become adults in society and
we need to make sure that they're fully
functioning and able to to stand up for
what they believe and what they know is
right and that starts from to and
getting them plenty of interaction with
people of all ages we do them a
disservice when we collect them and
segregate them into kids only of their
age in their class in school Ag and so
they're either on a screen or they're
surrounded by only their immediate peers
I just had the privilege to take my kids
on a um mission trip and it was a Young
Adult Ministry that I was the speaker
for but I said hey can I bring my kids
for the for the uh for the mission trip
part and we're painting and we're
working on a building and my kids are
interacting with all these young adults
and with with with youth at other times
and with little kids than them at other
times and they've got their actual
grandparents and then grandma and
grandpa so and so and grandma and
grandpa so and so and over here is uncle
and auntie this and that and beyond your
family so I really believe in the home
education model not as a way to prevent
socialization but as the best form of
socialization when kids are staring at
screens and they're age segregated that
is harmful to socialization actually
yeah I think most churches um they do
have a a problem by separating everybody
out I I I don't like the idea that you
don't have the churches interacting with
the elderly and with the youth and you
know sometimes it'll be like oh this is
a youth thing and they're over there
doing that I've I've learned so much by
hanging out with old people and actually
you know there you yeah right I know
seriously I mean I remember the days
that there was no cell phones or
technology in our pockets how about you
we used to dial the phone we would dial
the phone did you have a friend with a
lot of zeros
man this takes forever but no it's I
think it's something that we need to
encourage and I I think it's it's um
something that if you do this with your
children you take them to functions like
that and you integrate them with with
other people you'll see their
personalities start to to Blossom we'd
like to show it to you today for the
first time and we call it the
iPad Steve Jobs in 2010 was on the stage
at the Apple event releasing the the
iPad and he described it as as a
wonderful device that brought you
Educational Tools it allowed you to surf
the web it allowed you to watch videos
it allowed you to interact with other
people and he basically said it's the
best way to do all those things two
years later when he was asked uh your
kids must love the iPad he said actually
we don't allow the iPad in the home we
we think it's too dangerous for them in
effect the reason why he said that was
because he recognized just how addictive
the iPad was as a vehicle for delivering
things to people that once you had the
iPad in front of of you or when you took
it away from the home with you you'd
always have access to these platforms
that were very addictive that were hard
to resist so where his kids were very
well adapted well adjusted may not have
been Prime targets for say substance
abuse they like everyone else are
susceptible to the charms of something
like an iPad and what it delivers so the
question is why are Steve Jobs and Bill
Gates the people who are creating these
Technologies why are they so strict with
their kids media when you think they
might want to pass on things to their
children well this isn't some secret
hidden knowledge like the American
Academy of Pediatrics has said for many
years please no media for children under
the edge of two and that's not going
that far I think they're they're being
pretty wimpy on that if you ask me in
fact there was a period of time where
the AAP removed that recommendation the
Child Development community and
scientists and and everybody who knows
the the research on this was up in arms
they're like AAP American Academy of
Pediatrics the Guardians of children how
could you withdraw that recommendation
of please no media before the age of two
and then they put it back on
so they responded to pressure not
science um World Health Organization
yeah some problems there for sure but
one thing they got right is please no
screen time for children before the age
of five they said the less the better
before the age of five so these when you
interview these not just Bill Gates and
Steve Jobs but like I was mentioning the
engineers at the Silicon Valley firms
you say you know what why do you do it
the way you do it and what ages they are
waiting till later and the key is the
stimulant level if you're if you've got
a nature paced video uh research on that
does not show harm like Mr Rogers Pac
you know uh screen time Mr Rogers is
even slower than nature right so Dr
Demitri christakis at Seattle Children's
Hospital many years ago has shown when
children are watching cartoons when
children are watching regular
entertainment videos not to mention
interactive screen time which is an even
higher stimulant level it is harmful to
their attention span which is a proxy
for saying hurting their frontal
development so they will have more
Tantrums they will have less emotional
self-regulation more disruptive moods
and all the problems that go with in in
inhibited frontal lob so kit do has
found though when you have a control
group that's watching Mr Rogers they
don't have those same attention span
hits that the kids who are watching the
cartoons in the other videos so it's
stimulant is the key he was kind of
early coming out about um iPads too and
like concerns with there but he started
to back off his stance based on exactly
what you're saying was content so a
FaceTime video interaction is a
different thing exactly on an iPad than
you're playing Call of Duty sure it's a
different thing your brain perceives
that differently yeah they he he linked
um percentages of of attention deficit
um for every hour was 10% so if you're
playing with this stuff for two hours
out of the day that's 20% 30% so on and
so forth and you being a teacher
attention is the key yeah sure is and
now you have this you know generation of
people coming up that just literally
can't pay attention well you know it's
it to me it's not just the attention
span problems but it's what else that
means attention span deficits because of
environmental factors of overstimulation
are doing harm on so many levels so many
people would be like I don't really care
to read a book you know so what and it's
just for the kids in school and I'm
going no if you have if you are
shortening your attention span you know
the average attention span in the
industrialized world is now 8 seconds
it's shorter than that of a goldfish
Time Magazine and uh so all of us are
harming our prental cortex which is
going to be is where we engage in
impulse control if we want more
self-control in our lives we need that
prefrontal cortex and you think about
what that spills over into I mean just
going to church listening to stuff
totally hey here's a Ministry video
that's an hour oh that's too long I
can't watch that you know it's like you
you you're going to have a attention
problems throughout your life so I think
that the the the parenting if you guys
are out there and listening to this and
you have young children um um I hope
that you'll take these things seriously
look into them because you know um
building those those things into your
children and good habits good media
habits or good just like you know going
outside and doing good things is going
to have a lifelong lasting experience
but I like what's come out of this
conversation as well is if you have a
problem you can fix it so start today
just make those changes today and you
can begin to move forward and reverse
some of these things just nature and fun
it it's not that complicated be outdoors
be together and have a happy time and
kids come alive it could be said that
we're going back to extremes and that so
you have someone who's super addicted to
technology and then the other extreme is
no Tech at all for 5 days for someone
who can't do that practically is there a
way to get there without oh disengage
for five days in nature are you talking
about children
family children yes and then as as a
whole if I don't know anybody that can't
unless they're just like they've
expended all their vacation time you
know you you go on a vacation you go on
a you know 5day backpacking outing and
you leave the phones behind I mean do
something just try something radical I'm
not saying never use a phone again but
just see what happens when you do go you
know we're going to go as strict as
humanly possible on this and do
something radical you'll see the the
fruits and then that'll make you want to
get back to your normal Ed life with
proper limits I think maybe to address
maybe what she's getting at is there are
people
where they've never camped that's true
you know they've never like if you're
like Urban inner city this is your life
you know tall buildings around you you
know you get you go through a metal
detector go to school this kind of thing
like the countryside is like something
you've seen on the video screen or
you've saw pictures in books yeah so
what do you do if you're in that context
because going camping is like what what
yeah are you kidding me like what two
things to that and that's a really good
point because we've got a an issue of
access we've got an issue of the
underserved here and I mean underserved
in nature exposure and what they found
in studies is in that Urban setting the
closer you live to a park the better
your outcomes a great practice Park just
start with a park just like we go to the
park every single day we go for a walk
in the neighborhood where there are a
couple trees growing and the birds are
singing in even in the city so start
small but also I want to speak to those
who have the means and can reach into
those Urban settings and help and and
and Mentor people into how to experience
nature because you can't blame somebody
for being born in that and not knowing
it's like you got to really you got to
you got to help people along in that
context so exactly yeah shout out to
Pathfinders you know that was my camping
experience they would take all the kids
in the church like let's go let's go for
a weekend you know that's awesome yeah
yeah my kids are in Pathfinders and and
it's funny to to see the kids like
there's tons of kids that have just
never done that yeah you're like wow
parents get outside like come on but
yeah there's there's parks in almost
every city there's somewhere you can
walk I mean if you live in a
neighborhood walk outside just to get
outside go right a bike um I mean
usually you can you can get within a a
close proximity to some kind of nature
probably in a very short distance from
where you live I used to teach in the
inner city and there I'm from Michigan
and we got Lake Michigan it's one of the
most beautiful places in America people
don't understand how beautiful Lake
Michigan is sandy beaches it's like blue
like you're at the ocean you go to
Sleeping Bear do I mean I'm I'm I'm
right now for the Chamber of Commerce
here right I just love my state and it's
so beautiful and these kids were an hour
and a half and less than an hour and a
half from the lake shore they'd never
seen Lake Michigan wow I thought this is
a tragedy this is not okay and then they
did have this particular uh Urban School
District had a camp site that was owned
by the school district it was kind of
like a you know a getaway a place where
you can take the sixth graders and they
all got I was a sixth grade teacher my
first year teaching and everybody goes
out in sixth grade for one one outing to
that to that place now these were kids
who were really struggling and this is
2003 so this is before you know the
digital Revolution but they're from
struggling homes fatherless homes many
of them just in in those underprivileged
situations behavior problems in the
classroom as soon as we're out there it
doesn't take five days y they're coming
alive and so that's just a beautiful
thing because there's so much research
this isn't just anecdotal right there
are thousands of studies on nature
exposure and the benefits to your brain
to your happiness to your behavior right
I you know it we're picking on media
here but it's not just media like my
kids are um 13 and or no 14 and 12 and
they're at that age where it's like he
looked at me she did this she talked to
me she touched my stuff and I mean it's
like fight fight fight fight fight right
I kick him outside it's like all of a
sudden they get along what are you doing
like what what like is it the sun is it
the what it's something in the air but
it it it just it really does solve a lot
of things just to spend a little time
outside you sure does negative ions in
the air fresh air sunlight green even
even if you're indoors and you're
surrounded by green and office settings
it reduces stress even if you're near a
window I mean you get measurable
benefits what about
neon K's like we need more plants
absolutely cut a hole in the ceiling
that's right um we talked about uh the
different effects of of media addiction
or like Society being so engrossed in
media and the people who are controlling
it well they're getting money and and
power and all these things can you touch
on what is um can you touch on the
effect of collective thinking versus
individuality oh yeah the group mind the
group mind um this is Edward Bernay and
I was a history teacher before I was a
Bible teacher and I would teach my
students about the 1920s in Mass popular
culture and this nephew of Sigman Freud
named Edward Bernay and how he in his
book he wrote a book called propaganda
so this is not hidden this is not you
know not some secret thing he said we
are there to control the group mind and
they won't even know about it he says
the conscious and intelligent uh
manipulation of the organized w habits
and opinions of the masses is an
important element in a Democratic
Society and he says we are governed our
minds molded our tastes formed our ideas
suggested largely by men we have never
heard of that was 100 years ago they had
techniques in place to do that 100 years
ago how much more today you were
mentioning these guys who go to Stanford
they're all in the same class and
they're in the persuasive technology
laboratory going to then work for big
Tech persuasive by the way if you're
doing things unconsciously manipulating
people's behavior and choices that's not
persuasion I believe in Persuasion come
now let us reason together the Bible
says and bernes was pedaling his Wares
to big companies and you know giving
them the idea that um you know we have
to make sure I have a quote that I share
with people it's from the 1929 Harvard
Business Review where he's basically
saying you know we have to teach people
to want new things to desire new things
before the old have been entirely
consumed right and I always ask people
when do you think that was written you
know and I get a variety of answers a
lot of people guess like the 1950s and I
told yes it's 1929 Harvard Business
review and when you go through the quote
you're like did it work and they're like
yeah it worked yeah it worked Hook Line
and Sinker why is it inherently wrong
and if so why group thinking they should
have ethics classes next to those
persuasive classes like if you're doing
things causing the the group to do
harmful
activities that just seems wrong and and
I know Edward beray is one of the things
that he helped um women didn't smoke
back then I think is what what he his
his uh big thing was teaching the the
cigarette companies how to make that
acceptable in society well you're
ruining People's Health so you could use
that technique to maybe push Society in
the right direction or make people do
the right thing I think I think
everything that we experience in
Psychology and the way our systems work
and everything right God created that
system the devil is perverting that
system so I mean imagine if everybody um
was exercising and doing good things and
the group think was like hey go out and
help your neighbor do good things I mean
society would change like that right but
but what if you're so accustomed to just
going with the group and it's always
making the good choice but then the 99th
time out of a hundred they are going the
wrong direction you're not prepared to
stand alone that's right so you know
that's why we got to be transformed not
conformed that's right the Bible doesn't
call us to be conformed to that which is
good in society only that which is God
that's true so we Behold Him we become
changed you know what we behold we
become more like right so if we're
looking at our fellow man which
direction are they going taking my cues
from the Trends on social media and I
like gen Z by the way I really like gen
Z when I started doing when I started
doing media on the brain seminars it was
my Millennial younger younger friends
you know we're we're ex right okay so we
just got to get things straight here
there's no are you Millennial or X I'm
like borderline it depends on what take
as a definition we got Z and we got X
but I but I what I notice in myself is
because I'm kind of close year-wise okay
I have traits of both oh traits of both
good good good but you know a lot of
times the young people could not stand
the media on the brain oh big bad media
on the brain guy Scott Ritz is coming
but then I noticed recently I go to an
academy a young people speaking to high
schoolers and they're coming up to me
like this is super helpful you know we
we we we see this in our own age group
and how can we you know it's engaging in
dialogue and interest and that jenz has
an openness because they didn't know
life without this stuff and so they're
skeptical of it not everyone but it's
more so than the millennial generation I
love everybody by the way if you're
listening to this in your Millennial
it's probably half the audience but um I
love everybody and I don't think that
highly of Gen X because honestly we were
latchy kids and have an excessive IND
dependence sometimes and obnoxious
individuality and so we can talk about
the collective and the group mind is so
bad but also we got to find a balance as
well but J Z's challenge is too
collectively thinking too much going
along with the group and so develop that
strength of character as an individual
is how I would admonish the young people
today and say be willing to be dare to
be a Daniel you know dare to be like
Shadrach Meshach and Abednego cuz the
times are coming
where you're not going to have the the
support and the comfort of your Society
of your peer group of young and old I
mean the arm of Flesh will fail you and
every Earthly support will be cut off so
but not Jesus every Earthly support so
you stay connected to Jesus he tells you
who you are your identity is found in
him your strength grows up in him and
then you serve your fellow man instead
of follow that's good and the training
for that the preparation Starts Now in
the home with with the children yeah I
like what you said earlier there's a
difference between persuasion versus
manipulation and when it comes to
answering the question isn't inherently
wrong I would say yes I mean
manipulation in any form is wrong and
you brought up uh going down to the end
times when we have to make just
salvation in general it's an individual
decision and Christ looks at the heart
is this person genuine in their decision
or are they just going on with the crowd
and you brought come let us reason to
together God is in the business of
persuasion presenting all the facts and
you make a choice whereas now in this
generation seems like doesn't even
matter whether the facts are true or not
or if there's any facts at all if
everyone's walking on the street hey I'm
going to join with them even to the
point of not even questioning why so let
me ask you a question if we could use
hypnotism in a in an Evangelistic
meeting to persuade to to get everybody
to accept Christ should we use that
method why not
abely Tak Choice yeah exactly God is all
about free choice I mean that's what
this whole mess that we're into right
now is demonstr is God's ability to say
in a in a in a Heavenly environment it
has to operate under free choice and
there's going to be people that are
making the wrong choice I don't think
it's right to force somebody or to
manipulate them because then you're just
creating robots so true and you know
there was that documentary the social
dilemma and you get all these
whistleblowers like we were talking Sean
Parker earlier and a number of guys
James Williams and they're all coming
out Tristan Harris and these guys are
saying this is manipulation that's going
on and they're conscience stricken about
it and so to have you know Edward beray
is tell us what he's doing as some sort
of Evil Genius sounding guy and then
these other people who are who are
saying you know what there's a problem
here and you need to think about how you
are being programmed that's a direct
quote from one of
them yeah so yeah be careful what you
read be careful what you watch it all
has influence you know and so what
always tell people you know what do you
want to be more influenced by do you
want to be more influenced by God or do
you want to be more influenced by the
world because like you said you're going
to conform to what you're
beholding so at the end of the day
that's the principle you guys you guys
taught about mirror neurons didn't you
we we we do yeah it's like what you see
your brain takes it in as if you are
doing it yourself not just seeing it so
you talk about it do you talk about it
in the context when children are very
young all of the above yeah but
especially they're more impressionable
at that age yeah so when they're young
so for our audience those that that
maybe have never heard of this mirror
neurons especially important when
children are young
because the these are neurons that are
very active and they have motor neurons
too so they're learning to move and and
those kind of things but motor neurons
also have another function motor neurons
are involved in conventional Jud
judgment making so frontal Lo activity
the problem is they're not as active in
the conventional judgment making as they
are their physical development but the
mirror neurons are very active this
Monkey C Monkey Do neuron the nickname
and so when a child is very young you'll
know this you know why does a little
girl want take care of a baby why does a
little boy want to work with tools right
because they saw mom and dad do that
thing whatever they're observing that's
what they're doing and so it becomes
very important that's why I tell people
you can never tell your child don't do
as I do do as I say right never works
because children are biochemically wired
the exact opposite way that's true which
then matters what kind of content you're
watching if you're watching people do
sinful Act if you're watching people do
awful things then you know what I mean
your brain is interpreting that and
actually acting as if it was doing it
itself y so and Jesus was way ahead of
that because he said you have heard that
it was said don't kill don't commit
adultery but I'm telling you don't even
have those things going on in your heart
lust and hate toward toward others so
it's really the Commandments are written
on our hearts for a reason because God
wants to transform our minds not just
our Behavior right and so that idea that
you will be affected by it it's it's a
law of the mind there's no way around it
and it might be imperceptible you might
not notice it but you might be the frog
in the pot right that's imperceptible
but the Frog ends up dying right it
start it all starts in the mind whatever
is in the mind will eventually become
those actions that will become those
habits you know that will become who you
are your character and so that speaks to
the point oh I'm just watching it I'm
not participating in it speaks to that
principle absolutely in your heart yeah
well and are you funding it as well
you're participating in that respect um
Romans 1:32 says knowing the Judgment of
God they which commit such things are
worthy of the Judgment that they're
doing those bad things you still you
you're worthy of that judgment and then
Paul brings it one step further and says
not only those that do those things but
those that take pleasure in them that do
them so I I I think that there's more
than just actually going through the
activity if you're like rooting on that
that person to do that awful evil thing
and I mean movies nowadays it's just
like I mean how many times have people
sat there and we hear this all the time
looking through Netflix you spend an
hour looking through it because it's
just junk I mean it's just awful like I
can't even find something wholesome to
watch you
know I think it matters you you still do
presentations yes yes we're doing more
digital presentations now I did 10 years
or so of the brick and mortar 400 plus
churches and traveling all over and
saying bye to my family and saying hi to
my family and so but yeah I still do I
still do presentations yeah what's the
name of your ministry belt of Truth
Ministries if you actually fact check
what he says you will come to the same
conclusion that we all have come to for
this and and so yeah built of Truth
Ministries check out um you've got
you've got also a YouTube page where
you've got a lot of material on your
YouTube page y so here's his YouTube
page we'll put a link um to the
description below but what what are they
going to find on your YouTube page a lot
of Media stuff and Bible teachings and
current events and prophecy study of
history and social control Mass
formation um parenting seminar
uh just miscellaneous topics we're doing
Health topics as well so yeah it's a
it's a smattering it's a smorgus board a
veritable Feast of uh goodness and Truth
we we named ourselves belt of Truth
Ministries instead of media on the brain
because I'm like there's no way I'm
going to only want to talk about media
if we're going into Ministry and we're
going to do this I want many topics
leave the media thing you guys are the
real experts on that we we ended up with
more invitations on media than on the
other topics but I love talking about
them all awesome awesome belt of Truth
check it out you will not be
disappointed uh a true teacher from the
heart and uh thank you for coming by and
blessing us with your information
obviously we could sit here and circle
around and talk about these for a long
time but uh we hope that the takeaway is
that um you'll take seriously that that
media is not just some form of um uh
passive entertainment it actually has an
influence upon our our brains our
decisions and um look into this if you
have young children look into this fact
check it watch the videos and then go by
and do a little bit of Internet research
we live in an amazing day and age where
you can research stuff pretty easily and
so um check it out and uh please if you
want to communicate with him you can
leave him a comment and and we'll put a
link to uh to where you can get a hold
of him as well um but like this this uh
show if you want to share this with
somebody that you know someone has
children or wants to uh be blessed by
this please share this information with
them and um one way you can help our
ministry out is just hit that little
like button and um also the Subscribe
button if you want to see more content
like this if you have any questions we
want to answer those questions for you
as well but uh we thank you guys wearing
a cool shirt Scotty that from check this
out we've got some some threads that we
uh we like to make in our ministry uh we
have another Ministry called lightwear
and you can find those at lightwear do
shop mine particularly here says the
seventh day Sabbath and uh too is
rocking yeah Keith rocking one as well
and so um lightwear do shop you can get
a hold of those and um just a cool way
to wear God's word on your chest be a
witness and to you you never know you'll
get into an interesting conversation but
uh check it out like this video and
we'll see you guys on the next one
[Music]
if you're looking for good wholesome
educational content for your children
subscribe to our new channel little like
kids
[Music]
St